we learn sign language and skill for
five it's becoming second nature to sign
as well as speak for these five and
six-year-olds British sign language is
used in their lessons assemblies even
just chatting introduced initially at
Lyndhurst primary an older them to help
three pupils with hearing impairments
but staff have noticed the benefits it's
had two other children too got many
children in here who I've got autism and
for the first time since introduced in
sign language we've had them communicate
with us and you've got the quieter
children who would quietly just go and
say good morning to each other and I
noticed that as a school we are all
communicating better there are fifty
thousand children with hearing loss in
the UK but very few mainstream schools
teaching British sign language
Jade Kilduff is calling for that to
change after being told her brother
Christian would never be able to
communicate due to his disabilities she
taught him sign language hey a petition
she set up a month ago calling for basic
signing to be compulsory in schools has
around a hundred thousand signatures
already my Christian communicates by
using sign language and a lot of people
when talking to Christian they would
have to talk through me so they would
say Oh Jade how do you say this to him
ah what's he saying and I thought it was
unfair that he could only communicate to
me and like a few of my family members
and I thought if everybody just knew a
little bit of sign then it would make
the world more inclusive the Department
for Education says schools have the
freedom to include sign language in
their curriculum if they wish to do so
Bharti rouser has seen how easily it's
been woven into teaching here
in stark contrast to the torment she
experienced as a child not being able to
hear and communicate at school
what is when I could school teachers to
to take not like this I but I with my
brain
each the change took Tommy family there
are 12 million people with hearing loss
in the UK around one in six people
teaching children like this isn't just
about communication it's about equality
Sally Lockwood Sky News Oldham